[Música]
quiero empezar mi primer plática pero de
hecho es la primera que digo es mi
primera plática que puedo compartirles
la historia con una frase que dice si
crees que puedes hacer algo o piensas
que no puedes hacer nada en las dos
tienes razón esta frase la escribió
henry ford y en su momento que la leí
que fue hace mucho tiempo no lo entendí
y pues eso me queda más claro que todo
lo que hagamos o dejemos de hacer
depende completamente de nosotros
usted nos invita a compartir ideas
y valores como visión vigor y voz creo
que son valores que yo vivo en mi día a
día y en lo que hago y me dedico
en lo que hago hoy
soy busco gómez un artista y emprendedor
potosí no se evita el regio y a mi me
encanta crear desarrollar conceptos
pensar en ideas hacer arte tratar de
pensar diferente
tener soluciones creativas
les voy a contar tres historias que me
definen lo que soy hoy y quiero empezar
con la primera
que empecé a mis 15 años de edad
yo llegué al tec era
las 7 de la mañana mi primer clase y lo
que me dan es esto
lo primero que veo es que me están
intentando vender pizzas hasta arriba en
la esquina y la entrada no me gustó
entonces yo dije yo quiero hacer una
agenda porque tenía todo
lo que nos había dicho el tec digo no
tenía nada que nos había dicho el tec
que nos iba a enseñar visión sentido
humano emprendedurismo entonces me
decidí a crear una agenda me di cuenta
que vemos el reloj vemos el tiempo en
forma circular en nuestros relojes y de
ahí nace
la primera idea que tengo para esta
agenda se pare
las rayas a lo largo de la hoja de las
hojas y me contacte con la diseñadora
mexicana que vivía en alemania en ese
momento y tras mails y bocetos llegamos
al primer diseño de la agenda
es un reloj de 24 horas
por páginas se separa en dos días
empieza a las 8 de la mañana y termina a
las 8 de la noche que son las horas que
creo que un emprendedor está funcionando
entonces si se fijan hay un sol un
solícito y una luna que nos indica la
transición y así es como se veía la
primera vez que escribí en mi agenda
podía escribir para arriba para abajo
para un lado para otro podía expresarme
podía ser más creativo y no tan lineal
como esa agenda que me dieron aquella
vez en el primer día en el tecnológico
de monterrey puse
quise incluir también dos frases
motivacionales
o sea una por día y al final de cada
domingo un artículo que me pudiera
enseñar y que me pudiera enseñar que me
pudiera decir o dar recomendaciones de
qué libros leer entonces habían 52
artículos motivacionales
y 365 frases también motivacionales
y ser la portada muy simple y
minimalista decía 365 días que te van a
cambiar
naidoo fue el nombre que le titulé que
no significa nada y es la agenda para
emprendedores dentro de prisión entonces
decidí de ya que la tenía decidí es que
hago con esto donde lo supo lo que
quiero que más gente lo vea hizo un
proyecto en kickstarter
y puse como meta mil dólares para que se
fundía el proyecto y 26 días
también para que se pudiera realizar
creo que el resultado fue muy
sorprendente para mí porque pude tener
358 patrocinadores y se juntaron 400
digo 4 mil 928 dólares en un plazo de 26
días yo no tenía página de internet no
tenía instagram no tenía nadie conocía
este proyecto y creo que llamó mucho la
atención porque hubo muchas visitas y
muchas compras también van de estas
agendas habrá silván de estas agendas a
china a españa a eeuu bueno en fin a 3
158 lugares diferentes de este mundo
me quedo con una frase que quise incluir
que me mencionó mucho macarena mi
hermana ella es bailarina profesional
que dice yo amo lo que hago esa incluye
el día de su cumpleaños en la agenda y
en ese momento yo no sabía que amaba lo
que hacía pero me quede más claro entre
otras cosas pinto no sé si se dieron
cuenta aquí tengo
una canastita con pelotitas de colores
los colores están alrededor de nosotros
en todos lados
pero ustedes ven los colores solos y no
significan nada
empiezan a tomar vida cuando los
empezamos a combinar
si quieren se los puedo enseñar y warren
- porque ahorita
ahorita los vamos a necesitar
entonces empiezo a pintar a la edad de
nueve años empiezo a pintar porque nací
con un síndrome en mi brazo derecho que
se llama club hand este síndrome
naces sin hueso radio y el cúbito más
corto y sin pulgar entonces desde muy
chiquito mis papás me metieron a clases
para no iba a poder escribir con la mano
derecha me empecé a hacer zurdo
en dos años puedo escribir con la mano
izquierda y eso es lo que dicen los
doctores que
está en mi hemisferio derecho que son
patrones cruzados que es el de la
creatividad y como arte de magia se
empezó a pintar
de un día para otro y cada vez empecé a
hacer pinturas más pensadas de hecho ahí
está un gusanito y ese gusanito tiene la
cara de donald trump
si alcanzan a verlo son radio mexicano
empecé pintando la cocina de mi casa hay
15 metros cuadrados que sobraban hasta
un mes después que los frijoles solían
aerosol me cambié a mi segundo taller
según taller medida 30 metros cuadrados
de la nada empecé a pintar formatos
grandes y más grandes y más grandes y
más grandes
hasta llegar al taller que tengo ahorita
que mide 150 metros cuadrados
es el único espacio que no tengo para
hacer tanta loquera
entonces
cada vez que pintaba y pintado más me
fui dando cuenta que
me especialicé en ser animales caras y
figuras humanas y yo necesitaba
encontrar como artista queremos creer y
hacer cosas diferentes
entonces yo sabía que se venía el gran
premio de méxico de fórmula1
bueno ya había estado los dos años
previos
ganó ganaron los 12 meses previos el
mejor evento del año
dije quiero pintar coches porque quiero
pintar coches porque
son fierros es diferente es una energía
diferente que las carnes y los animales
y me encantaría experimentar con un tema
diferente entonces tiene inicio
una colección que le hice al piloto
mexicano sergio pérez
es un tríptico
se iba a colgar para hacer honor a la
bandera de méxico ese es su casco
durante seis meses empecé a trabajar en
esta colección ese es un díptico que se
llama checo versus checo porque cuando
estuve estudiando todo este tema de la
fórmula uno
leí un artículo que se me quedó muy
grabado que decía
los pilotos corren no sólo corren contra
los demás pilotos sino contra ellos
mismos contra sus miedos contra sus
preocupaciones y contra todo lo que
tienen adentro entonces pues uno va a
estar en alguna parte del mundo y el
otro va a ser en alguna parte del mundo
y siempre estarán compitiendo esas
cuadras se conversa checo esto ayuda en
mi taller para correr y correr
y quise enfocarme en hacer detalles de
la fórmula-1 diferentes que nunca se han
visto encuadres
diferente sea y trae una llanta cortada
y luego otra llanta
además
yo
quería darle la emoción y la adrenalina
que tiene o trae consigo la fórmula uno
no sabía cómo hacerlo entonces con
varios con varios intentos y varios
tryouts
llegué y
le pegue a la velocidad
así es como quedó la colección
en los cascos me imaginé como si
estuviera avanzando el coche y chocando
la cabeza contra el asiento por eso
tantos energía saliendo checo versos
checo
gran formato
entonces faltaban 15 días para el gran
premio de méxico y yo terminé la
colección pero yo no sabía qué hacer yo
quería tener mis cuadros ahí yo me
enfoqué en pintar y no sabía cómo pero
yo quería estar el gran premio en méxico
entonces
en 24 mensajes de whatsapp me contacte
con un directivo de telmex y telcel y le
expliqué dije yo sé que ustedes
patrocinan a checo pérez cómo le hago
para estar ahí con ustedes
entonces
faltaban 15 días mandé el mensaje y lo
vio a los 5 minutos pasó un día para
otro día nos otro día yo dije pues esta
colección de gran formato que ya
llevamos seis meses haciéndola pues ya
se va a quedar en mi taller entonces
al sexto día al quinto día mayor este
mensaje
la verdad les digo algo yo no me la
creía
le dije a mis amigos mi papá a mi
hermano yo no se me estaba haciendo una
broma yo dije bueno es un teléfono de
méxico una tal claudia pues voy a marcar
este hay pueden ver la fecha dice 20 de
octubre la fórmula 1 fue el 30 de
octubre 30 y primero de noviembre
entonces
pues lleve los cuadros y así es como se
veían colgados
sabemos que esto no es atravesar
y la tercera historia que les quiero
contar
nace en madrid el año pasado en 2017
me fui con mis amigos después de acabar
la prepa y me metí al museo thyssen
bornemisza que es uno de los museos
privados más grandes de madrid
me contacte con la art project manager
raquel y platicando todas mis historias
la pintura que hago y pintó ocho horas
diarias etcétera
me dijo vos que conoces
o ha sido hablar de django berlín
te digo la verdad sinceramente no sé
quién es de django berlín es un
era un artista del siglo 16 que hacía
tapetes
y se puso a hacer los tapetes pero los
empezó a colgar en las casas de las
personas entonces empezó a hacer obras
de arte en los tapetes
se conoce hoy en día esos zapatos
colgados son tapices como gobelinos s
bosco con lo que estoy escuchando tú lo
deberías de poner a tu técnica vos
golino en su honor
entonces les voy a explicar que son bosc
gol y no un boss gol y no es una foto de
una pintura mía
se toma una foto en muy alta definición
se imprime esa foto en un papel metálico
que el papel metálico le da cierto
brillo
y
se plancha una
un pedazo de acrílico una pedazo de
acrílico exactamente el mismo tamaño que
la foto y luego le aviento pintura o le
hecho pintura arriba del acrílico
entonces tenemos un cuadro que es mitad
pintado mitad foto eso es un molino y
tiene tres características como son
fotos que puede imprimir cuando yo
quiera
se imprimen en series cortas solo de tal
cuadro que pinte solo se hacen cinco
molinos
y lleva dos firmas que es la firma del
original más la firma que va arriba del
acrílico
y que lleva la pintura arriba de mi
pintura
les enseño para que les quede más claro
esto es una pintura que yo hice parece
foto pero es pintura
tiene muchos detalles me tardé un mes y
medio en hacerlo
esa es una foto tomada con mi teléfono
de mi pintura
esa es la foto impresa con el acrílico
arriba entonces si no sé si
no se alcanzan a ver el reflejo ahí de
mi pie que está esté dentro de los
zapatos
y
estos son bosc gol y no esa es la
pintura que lleva arriba
del acrílico entonces esa es mi historia
ese soy yo y quiero cerrar con la frase
que dice crear me entusiasma emprender
me reta pero el resultado final no se
compara muchas gracias
[Aplausos]